bonjour à tous le mariage pour tous aura
aussi concerner les régions la bourgogne
et la franche comté se sont
officiellement unis le 1er janvier
dernier pour le meilleur et pour le pire
alors neuf mois après est ce que c'est
le pire ou est ce que c'est le meilleur
qui a pris le dessus on en discute dandy
manchot politique en bourgogne franche
comté avec autour de la table trois
témoins privilégiés de ce mariage
patrick ayache
bonjour bonjour vous êtes vice président
socialiste du conseil régional notamment
en charge des fonds européens du contrat
de plan et du tourisme
face à vous pascal grappin bonjour
bonjour eric sicaud vous représentez le
groupe de droite et du centre et vous
êtes conseiller régional u10 et puis à
côté de vous il avait lé de lyon vous
est également conseillère régionale bon
jour pour jour représenter le groupe
front national
jeudi dernier a eu lieu le premier
congrès des régions de france depuis la
création des nouvelles régions et manuel
valls a amené un cadeau de mariage
il a répondu à la principale
revendication des régions en annonçant
que leur action sera financé à partir de
2018 par le transfert d'une fraction de
tva et non plus par la dotation
financière de l'état c'est à dire la
fameuse dotation globale de
fonctionnement il a ajouté
l'effet dynamique garantira et
pérennisera vos moyens d'action alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
patrick ayache est ce que ça veut dire
que désormais les moyens des régions ne
dépendront plus de la bonne volonté des
gouvernements
c'est exactement ça et l'annoncent du
premier ministre nous a véritablement
satisfait puisque vous le savez comme
toutes les collectivités territoriales
des régions dépend des pour des parts
importantes d'une dotation versée par
l'état qui chaque année lors de la loi
de finances variés et l varié il faut
bien le dire ces dernières années à la
baisse à la baisse donc de visibilité
c'est absolument pas de visibilité
une crainte et des répercussions
éventuellement sur la fiscalité des
ménages pour compenser ces baisses de
notation à compter de 2018
désormais c'est une part de la tva qui
sera qui va remplacer sept
dotations de l'état et cette part de la
tva va véritablement donnée aux régions
l'autonomie financière que nous
souhaitions mais en même temps la
perspective d'avoir des recettes
dynamiques sont liées à l'évolution de
la consommation et surtout j'insiste qui
ne nous obligera pas à user de la
fiscalité supplémentaire pour les
ménages
c'est donc une très très bonne nouvelle
alors le président des régions de france
philippe richert là aussi salué cette
droite important il à nice et il a dit
c'est une révolution est ce que vous
êtes sur cette même longueur d'onde
pascal grappin
alors écoutez moi j'ai j'ai déjà envie
pousser un grand ouf de soulagement
parce qu'il faut dire que dans cette
problématique de financement des régions
la machine socialiste a créé de l'impôt
et de la taxe était lancée puisque le
gouvernement vole voulait et souhaitait
une taxe spéciale a été abandonnée qui a
été abandonné mais cette taxe spéciale
c'était quand même 600 millions d'euros
de prélever sur à la fois les ménages et
les entreprises
alors si cette taxe a été abandonné il
faut quand même le dire c'est parce
qu'il y a une une fronde très forte de
la part de certains présidents de région
et je crois qu'il faut pas oublier que
c'est quand même
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse hervé
morin christian estrosi qui ont poussé
pour que cette taxe ne soit pas mise en
oeuvre vous savez on a habitué avec les
socialistes
il ya un problème égale un impôt ou une
taxe bon ben là c'est ce mal car là
c'est pas le cas donc c'est pourquoi
j'ai j'ai un profond où ce de
soulagement quand j'ai quand même une
inquiétude matière de simplification là
vous faites fort j'ai quand même une
inquiétude
j'ai une inquiétude parce que le le
premier ministre a fait cette annonce
met un il n'a pas dit comment ça allait
fonctionner et là il faut s'attendre
je dirais à ce que bercy met de la
simplification dans dans tout ça je
crains j'ai très peur de voir ces
derniers la ridt et oui tout à fait et
puis le deuxième point c'est que le
premier ministre n'a pas dit comment
l'état allait financer le manque à
gagner
ça c'est quand même très important il ne
l'a pas dit alors julien c'est à dire le
manque à gagner
le
une recette qui est dynamique oui avant
cette recette était dans le budget de
l'état
l'état va perdre ah oui c'est trop cette
dynamique mais non qu'il va y avoir des
facteurs un manque à gagner sera pas moi
ce que ce que j'aimerais c'est d'avoir
entendu comment ça va se passer
en tous les cas ce que j'ai compris
c'est que 2018 c'était plus son problème
non je sais ce que je dois faire réagir
le lieu ne sera pas n'a pas tout compris
mais volontairement je le crois parce
que je sais qu'il est extrêmement
intelligent et qui la saisit
parfaitement la mécanique
cette dotation est supprimé c'est donc
une économie pour l'état puisqu'il
n'aura plus à la verse et aux
collectivités à la place juste un
transfert ce transfert de tva
je vous donner un chiffre
approximativement je crains pour la
région ont pris tout pour la région
bourgogne franche comté c'est environ en
arrondissant les chiffes 225 millions
d'euros qui désormais 235 milliards
seront plus assujettis à un risque de
diminution qui a pesé depuis plusieurs
années et qui au contraire va pouvoir
évoluer en fonction de l'évolution de la
capacité financière de notre pays
c'est donc une excellente nouvelle mon
cher pascal grappin vous devriez vous en
régionale
alors pascal grappin vous pourrez réagir
ensuite mais madame de lure l'arbre
s'est passé souvent que la droite salue
même s'il ya des bémols une une décision
gouvernementale
qu'en pense le front national vous êtes
plutôt favorable à cette option nous
nous sommes totalement opposés à cette
option
a paris si elle dotation parce que cela
démontre une fois de plus que la fusion
des régions ne génère aucune économie
contrairement à ce qui nous avait été
présenté donc on a déjà eu
l'augmentation de la dune haut de la
carte grise
nous avons échappé de peu au projet ter
sur la valeur locative foncière s'est
abandonnée mais certainement
provisoirement il aura d'autres
tentatives maintenant la dernière idée
du premier ministre c'est ce transfert
de tva donc pour nous
cette systématiquement une volonté
imposées par l'europe pour se calquer
sur l'organisation des länder allemands
nous nous sommes pour le triptyque
commune département nation est
totalement opposé au schéma métropole
méga région europe que l'on veut nous
imposer et ce transfert de compétence
transfert de tva ça va dans ce sens mais
pas toujours à l'usé refinancer éloigné
toujours plus le les gens des centres de
décision et il faut le financer d'accord
mais il ya eu un transfert de
compétences économiques du département à
la région
donc en théorie on devrait aussi avoir
un transfert des financements
correspondants pour assumer cette
nouvelle fonction donc on ne comprend
pas bien pourquoi d'un seul coup il faut
trouver des financements ailleurs une
réaction parce qu'elle a simplement de
deux points pour madame de lyon ii
justement le transfert la loi n'a pas
prévu au niveau de la compétence
économique il ya un transfert financier
des départements des relations ça pose
un problème mais vit ça pose un problème
des six blessés voilà faut s'adresser
manque à ceux qui dirigent à fond
monsieur monsieur ayache moi je suis
très inquiet que vous n'ayez pas compris
je dirais ce qu'il va se passer
mécaniquement au niveau du budget de
l'état je sais bien que ça va être une
opération blanche à 0 un instant t je
suis d'accord mais si c'est une recette
dynamique pour les régions elle n'est
plus dynamique pour l'état et moi je
voudrais savoir comment l'état va
financer la paix j'ai bien d'avouer à
non vous l'aviez pas compris pour la
région c'est une bonne chose mais le
premier ministre de la région s'est bien
gardé de dire comment est ce qu il
allait comment est ce qu'il allait faire
donc oui moi je pense que c'est une
c'est effectivement une une bonne chose
ça va permettre de donner une autonomie
financière à la région le reste c'est
qu'ils en profitent quand même pour
augmenter le taux de tva à terme c'est
ce qui risque de se produire rapidement
pour terminer là dessus et ben écoutez
je crois que finalement on a tout dit ou
presque sur cette question il n'y a pas
de risque d'augmentation du taux de la
tva vous savez que ça répond à des
mécanismes européens qui aujourd'hui ne
sont pas près de se débloquer dans ce
sens et comment
après la tva concernant la parc de
dynamisme qui va échapper à l'état vous
avez raison sur ce point mais ça
représente une toute petite partie
d'attirer à ce transfert
donc il faut rester globalement positif
et se satisfaire se satisfaire vraiment
je le pense que ces nouvelles régions
qui sont désormais les moteurs de
l'économie de notre pays vont pouvoir
gérer les affaires économiques
les transports et toutes leurs
compétences sans dépendre de l'état
c'est ça qui est un véritable pas en
avant et on vérifiera tout ça dans les
années à venir alors nous jeudi en même
temps que manuel valls faisait cette
annonce le nom de la bourgogne franche
comté a été officialisée par un décret
paru au journal officiel alors est ce
que pour vous c'est rentré dans les
moeurs on peut avoir des doutes je vais
vous citer de réflexion de nos
internautes fab qui nous diffusions
imposé ne fais pas mon mariage
et puis jp à besançon ils disent franche
comté bourgogne
c'est vrai ça je sais pas je n'ai pas
que j'étais aussi je suis bisontin fier
de l'être et mais moi je dis bourgogne
franche comté et jeudi bourguignon franc
comtois
alors je reconnais que c'est un peu long
mais c'était le nom de la région qui
s'imposait compte-tenu des deux cultures
qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui fusée mais
l'impression que c'est en traînant je
pense dans les neuf mois après alors en
tout cas du temps de toute manière voilà
en tout cas la fusion je peux vous le
dire elle d'abord nous lisions avant
l'émission
la loi est là donc maintenant il faut
évidemment l'assumer et ne plus être
nostalgique du passé
et puis autour de nous que nous sommes
entre politiques là mais la société
civile les associations les entreprises
mais elle nous devancent en matière de
dynamisme et ça c'est pas en matière en
matière de dynamisme et vous
sont déjà assez clair max est déjà dans
la fusion ou non mais ne vous moquez pas
pas des associations du monde économique
effective en tout cas ça s'est passé pas
si simplement écouter marie-guite dufay
elle s'est exprimée à ce sujet jeudi à
reims on l'interrogé sur nous on était
cette réorganisation écoutez sa réponse
est très court c'est beaucoup beaucoup
de travail pour réunir deux
administrations 5000 personnes à la clé
c'est compliqué je ne le cacherai pas
alors pourquoi c'est compliqué ben c'est
compliqué parce que il y a deux régions
deux administrations qui vivaient leur
vie comme toutes les autres régions il
faut en faire une seule
et puis en même temps que nous
construisons cette nouvelle région
il faut que les trains arrivent à
l'heure il faut que les lycéens puissent
déjeuner dans les restaurants scolaires
des lycées etc etc
donc il faut conduire à la fois
l'ambition qui est la nôtre de
développer ce territoire et la fusion de
ces deux régions mais nous y arrivons
très bien le fait que ce soit compliqué
je pourrais vous donner un certain
nombre de chiffres
aujourd'hui sur les premiers résultats
de cette fusion ils sont tout à fait
exceptionnelle et nous sommes
probablement vous allez nous les données
régionales et nous sommes probablement
dans le peloton de tête des régions en
match des régions fusionner en matière
de regroupement de nos services l'avion
ça n'est pas du tout notre point de vue
je trouve pas dans les faits la majorité
de l'activité se déroule à dijon il ya
un sous-emploi manifeste aller à l'hôtel
de région de besançon a besoin sont
certes un manque de travail alors qu'à
dijon
les employés sont absolument débordées
l'organisation est inefficace elle est
source de retard dans beaucoup de
domaines dans les conseils
d'administration des lycées auxquels
nous participons on se plaint des
retards dans les décisions
l' agence régionale de développement en
franche-comté indique que les décisions
sont en attente sur beaucoup de dossiers
cela génère des problèmes de trésorerie
et menace la stabilité de lagence le
personnel des deux entités est également
dans la tente d'une réorganisation qui
ne vient pas et cela engendre un stress
qui nuit à l'efficacité
alors madame de lui on parle de deux
décident de besançon de dijon est ce que
c'est pas l'erreur originelle finalement
d'avoir voulu les organisations au site
est ce que ça ne participe pas à
l'éparpillement des centres de décision
je crois que nous avions eu il ya
quelques temps un débat à ce sujet et
j'avais exprimé effectivement ce point
de vue mais aujourd'hui c'est sûr que
c'est compliqué c'est sûr que c'est
difficile mais pendant un certain nombre
de mois monsieur ayache on nous a
expliqué que tout était prêt que depuis
2014 les services travaillaient qu'à la
fois les services de la région bourgogne
et les politiques de la région bourgogne
les services de franche comté les
politiques de franche-comté travailler
ensemble pour construire la région et
qu'on serait sur les rails dès le départ
n'est ni tout ça n'est ni tout c'est un
monsieur minutes
nenni aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
effectivement il ya quand même des
dysfonctionnements il suffit
d'interroger les acteurs qui sont au
contact de la région que ce soit le
monde économique le monde associatif
culturel sporting que vous distille ce
qu'il n'y a pas de réponse aujourd'hui
dans bon nombre de cas il n'y a pas de
réponse
il y a un nombre incalculable de
manifestations qui sont passés sans
qu'il y ait eu la moindre réponse sur
les demandes d'accompagnement de la
région
la région était aux abonnés absents
impact à écouter ça c'est la version de
pascal grappin c'est bien normal il est
dans ce rôle moi ce que je peux vous
dire en essayant et je crois que nous
devrions tous les trois essayer de le
faire de la même façon d'être objectif
oui ça a été préparée avant françois
patriat et marie-guite dufay avait pris
en main en 2014 où vous l'avez dit en
est la préparation de cette fusion c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous sommes
effectivement en avance sur bien des
régions fusionner je vous donne quelques
exemples
le premier comité régional du tourisme
qui est devenue unique c'est celui de
bourgogne franche comté et dès le mois
d'avril
vous imaginez ce que ça représente ce
sont deux entités importante
il y en a désormais qu'une vous parliez
madame d'économie il y aura très bientôt
une seule agence régionale de
développement
c'est très compliqué à faire je ne le
renie pas mais ce sera fait dans les
bois qui viennent nous avions deux
administrations
quelques chiffres je vais aller vite
nous avions sur le temps passe vite d'où
l'avion 38 direction 38 direction en
additionnant les directions de chaque
ancienne région il n'y en a plus que 28
nous avions si dia cheville directeurs
généraux à ce droit vous ayez bien ap
les observations des syndicats vous
savez que mesdames la dgs à russia
soupçonné vendredi ont salué l' on salué
à absolument avec daisy si vous voulez
que je communique le mail qui était
envoyé par un grand syndicat qui porte
toutes ces interrogations et qui
explique qu'il n'y avait pas de réponse
à l'égard des personnels des agents ou
et bien sûr il ya des interrogations qui
sont et rien n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
directive ya passé ils ne savent pas
aujourd'hui comment faire qu'à l'envoyer
à cheveux un point moi qui me qui
m'énerve
vous pouvez pas imaginer
comment vous allez expliquer aux
salariés qu'il va falloir harmoniser les
régimes indemnitaires et qui va falloir
faire des efforts alors que vous même
les élus vous les avez pas fait sur les
indemnités s'est écrié on a dans le même
de ce syndicat c'est très serré en proue
bah oui j'étais là dessus justement pour
souligner qu' aucune des économies
envisageable n'ont été ne serait-ce qu
évoqué suppression du ceser par exemple
fusion des frac qui sont des griffes
réduction des indemnités des élus
rationalisation des emplois et par
contre on a énormément de coûts
supplémentaires comme l'augmentation des
frais de transport des doublons
d'emplois salariés etc
il n'y a aucune économies générées à ce
jour par la fusion des deux ans a lancé
je sais qu'une interrogation fi de nos
internautes et par exemple monique
inédite quel con merci de chiffrer les
dépenses et les économies nous dit-elle
à ce que la fusion coûte plus cher comme
le dit madame bisson l'instant dans la
réponse est claire vous le verrez dès la
présentation des orientations
budgétaires en novembre et dès le vote
du budget qui suivra la fusion des deux
régions coûte évidemment moins cher que
l'addition des deux anciennes régies
s'est ouvert ex supérieur 2015 déjà par
de chaudes très concret je vous dis vous
le verrez voyez quand on a fusionné les
deux crt ya bien le budget de teint des
deux du nouveau crt est moins important
que celui des deux anciens crt mais je
crois qu'il faut d'abord répondre à la
question que vous posez lui ceci qu sur
l'organisation be site
j'ai cru comprendre que monsieur rap
indé et oui c'est une erreur ah oui
parce que vous auriez imaginer les uns
et les autres que nous allions basculer
500 fonctionnaires de besançon vers
dijon où l' inverse en leur disant
écoutez désormais nous nous organisons
en mono site et donc nous abandonnons un
territoire complet non mais
nous revendiquons ce voyage et nous
revendiquons cher pascal grappin cette
organisation rose ou six national mall
nous la revendiquons malgré les trajets
incessants des trajets ça fait partie
des inconvénients du système mais
regardez l'état l'état s'est organisée
comme nous aujourd'hui direction
régionale de l'agriculture direction
régionale de l'emploi
ils sont organisés en bi site je
pourrais le faire sur l'ensemble des
directions
il n'y a pas d'autre solution regardez
les régions et la solution la royale et
les réaliser dans le rappeler à vos amis
prési re les olives est la même chose
que nous mais les régions sont pas
comparables entre elles
bien sûr les paras blanc très bien sûr
aujourd'hui en tous les cas on
s'aperçoit que cela ne fonctionne pas ça
ne fonctionne pas alors peut-être que ça
va mettre du temps mais pendant qu'on
est en pendant que vous êtes en train de
vous amuser dans un mécano administratif
et financier
les dossiers n'avancent pas est ce que
les bourguignons et franc-comtois alors
attente c'est que les dossiers avancent
à leur parlons des danses les
entreprises avancent vers les dossiers
justement est pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de plan de mandat on l'attend
toujours écouté ce que disait à ce
propos marie-guite dufay c'était encore
jeudi à reims
la priorité c'est de construire le
premier budget du mandat puisque nous
avons construit un budget en début de
mandat qui n'était qu'un budget qui
additionné les deux budgets de la
bourgogne et de la franche comté sans
faire véritablement de choix pour le
mandat et nous avons à adopter pour la
fin de l'année
notre plan de mandat c'est à dire nous
nous
engagements chiffrés en fonction de ce
premier budget ça c'est très important
autour de trois priorités le
développement de l'économie et l'emploi
à la clé la transition énergétique sont
toutes ses formes
et puis ce que j'appelle le vivre
ensemble avec la culture le sport qui
doivent être mis en exergue pour
favoriser le lien social
alors il serait temps de construire un
budget non françois sauvadet dans un
communiqué déclaré je suis stupéfait que
nous n'ayons pas encore de plan de
mandat oui j'ai entendu françois sauvé
les dire ça mais écouter la présidente
vous a quasiment tout dit nous avions
dit il y a 6 mois
notre plan de mandat nous le
présenterons à la fin de cette année
lors de la séance où nous évoquerons les
orientations dirais pas du tout pendant
cette année 3 millions cette année
c'est facile à écouter mois trois plans
d'urgence nous avons lancé trois plans
un plan sur l'emploi un plan sur le btp
un plan d'urgence sur l'agriculture
on n'a pas attendu le plan de mandat
pour faire des choses
vous parliez de la fusion des frac
madame ou en tout cas du rapprochement
des frac
ça y est c'est en cours nous travaillons
bien entendu que en même temps que nous
construisons ce plan de mandat en même
temps nous agissons le plan sur le btp
25 millions d'euros qui sont en ce
moment à louer à des communes ou des
opci lemoine mahmi d'habitants pour
développer le btp le cisaillage vous
êtes con vous à la 10 ème set quand est
ce que le budget d'investissement est
celle de jane investissez paris fera
augmenter ou va diminuer je vous donne
rendez-vous à la dm2 combien allez-vous
baisser le budget d'investissement de la
région de nyon des jours à la dfb ont
certains y voient la dm et on verra qui
a raison parce qu attendez vous savez
pertinemment et vous m'avez pas répondu
aman bien sûr qu'on attaque départ il a
déclaré m vous êtes vous m'avez pas
répondu sur les trois plans durant ce
voyage est long s'est précisée pour les
spectateurs
l'adn la décision modificative du budget
si c'est à dire que le budget a été voté
avec des sommes d'investissement
relativement importante
on n'arrête pas de nous expliquer qu'on
fait des plantes si des plans de ça et
qu'on développe l'investissement le seul
petit problème c'est qu'on transfère les
choses on a prévu 150 là on dit j'en
mets 10 mais on va réduire de 20 ans
résultat ça fait moins 10 mais vraiment
rare on va y aller moi je vous donne
rendez-vous mais à l'adn et vous verrez
la bc zurich la décision me dit que nous
appréciions e-label de lyon pour vous
c'est une année de perdue 2016 oui c'est
complètement et bon moi je voulais quand
même parler rapidement du problème
d'alstom parce qu'on l'a pas abordé
j'ai gardé son budget oui bien sûr mais
je vois que le temps passe et je crains
que qu'on n'en parle pas ça se savait en
question l'efficacité c'est ça que vous
les dévoile à l'efficacité de la région
donc on en a parlé hier lors de la
commission permanente parce que nous
avions un dossier qui nous a été soumis
qui proposait un financement
exceptionnel et bienvenue de 10000 euros
au comité d'entreprise d'alstom pour
participer à la manifestation à paris le
27 septembre
bon cette colère est légitime vous allez
voter contre hadj est ou non non nous
avons remonté pour cette colère est
légitime mais encore faut-il diriger
cette colère vers ceux qui sont
réellement responsable de cette
situation et madame dufay fait voter ce
financement comme si deux n'a rien
n'était alors qu'elle soutient emmanuel
macron n'est ce pas elle qui le trouve
particulièrement intéressant mais
coûteux rien à voir avec le débat que
nous avons entre nous
elle m'a qu'on n'est plus ministre dans
les camps mais c'est quand même lui qui
a été au moment dé de tout ce qui est
trop mignon nationale conseil régional
est ce que vous estimez l'euro les a
faits pour revenir ça on écoutait et
madame du fait puisque vous parler
d'elle était au lendemain de l'annoncé
sur la suppression
des centaines d'emplois sur alstom était
sur le site et le lendemain dans le
bureau du ministre de l'industrie
donc vous savez parce que là il faut
comme vous êtes dans l'opposition vous
avez le droit de contester nos décisions
mais vous n'avez pas le droit à la
mauvaise foi et nous faisons avec le
gouvernement avec le ministre qui
revient mardi prochain d'ailleurs sur
les lieux nous faisons tout ce qui est
en notre pouvoir pour essayer de faire
faire marche arrière à cette décision
dont je dis je suive ce que je vais dire
qu'elle est totalement inacceptable
elle est totalement réunion sur alstom
concerne d'ailleurs pas que alstom a lui
aussi des difficultés
d'ailleurs le logo dans le jura la spar
en saône-et-loire risque entre l
impuissance de la région à 8 pour
c'était ce genre de la le cas d'alstom
mais est quand même très très
symptomatique
moi je veux bien que des lendemains on
se déplace pour aller au chevet des
salariés
c'est la moindre des choses mais le
problème c'est quand même un problème
majeur de l'état avant tout je veux bien
derrière coopératif sur la région mais
quand on est actionnaire à 25% d'une
entreprise et convainc radon et que l'on
apprend comme ça subitement qui va y
avoir la fermeture d'un 6 et 5
la problématique mais j'ai cru qu'ils
étaient le choléra depuis un moment les
élus le savait en tout des cas des élus
du territoire de belfort avait déjà
alerté de façon significative les
pouvoirs publics et au plus haut niveau
de l'état
alors que maintenant vous arriviez pour
faire le pompier pour essayer d'aider à
un moment donné ses salariés j'ai envie
de dire c'est la moindre des choses
c'est la moindre des choses et nous le
faisons encore mais nous faisons et si
l'état mais j'ai confiance dans les
prochains rebondissements de ce dossier
j'espère ne pas me tromper si l'état
reste excusez moi je vais le dire un
conséquent comme il l'a été sur ce
dossier depuis quelques semaines je le
dis je le dis voiliers mais moi ça ne me
gêne pas je sais de lui rester objectif
effectivement la région prendra toutes
ses responsabilités toutes ses
responsabilités pour essayer de
reconstruire de reconstruire sur ce
territoire
l'industrie ferroviaire qui doit s'y
développer mais ce qui inquiète alors il
ya une réunion là dessus on aura le
temps aussi bien sur france 3 bourgogne
question france 3 franche comté de
revenir sur ce dossier alsthom il nous
reste vraiment une minute trente
je voudrais juste aller 20 secondes
chacun finalement répondre à notre
question initiale
est-ce que ce mariage il est heureux ou
pas pour vous isabelle de lyon ce que
vous vouliez la parle comme je voulais
déjà expliqué nous nous sommes contre
ces méga région donc ce mariage là ne
peut pas être heureux
pascal grappin je dirais c'est le
mariage de deux régions qui est on était
gouvernée trop longtemps par part des
socialistes des régions qui étaient en
grandissant celle ci fera gens c'est
bien là des régions qui étaient en
grande difficulté et je crois avoir dit
à une époque de marier un boiteux de la
jambe droite avec un boiteux de la jambe
gauche
ça fait pas quelqu'un qui marche au
droit il y aura du travail devait y
avoir beaucoup de travail
en tous les cas ce que l'on aimerait
nous c'est que rapidement il ya un cap
il ya des actions il ya des objectifs et
aujourd'hui on les a pas et je crains
qu'on ait un plan de 2 me mandate et par
un plan de mandat rapidement tapé très
rapidement bien sûr que c'est un mariage
heureux d'abord parce qu'il a été
précédée de fiançailles et que ça aide
et qu'ensuite un mariage heureux
c'est un mariage qui dure et quoi que
vous disiez facettes région
la vocation à durer vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure
probablement aucun législateur ne
reviendra en arrière mais c'est un
mariage heureux et nous et contribuant
pleinement
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette émission que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir bien sûr sur nos sites internet
dans un instant dimanche en politique se
poursuit avec francis letellier son
invité françois fillon ce sera juste
après flash régionales bon dimanche à
tous